amy is on the line and Panama City Beach
I Amy how are you hi Dave I'm good how
are you
better than I deserve what's up so I'm a
new listener by like 2 or 3 days I've
been listening and watching a ton of
your videos
I'm 51 I'm divorced no kids sorry
how long have you been divorced I'm
trying to get a hold of myself and I'm
blowing through the things that I have
how much savings I have four thousand in
my checking and I have eight thousand in
another investment accounts which
cryptocurrencies which I just watched
your video on that so I am currently
down on that right get that outside okay
I'm just put it in the same users
account you don't need to be risking
money right now you're broken out of a
job so what did you use to make it your
job what did you do I did project
management and I've also prior to moving
to Florida I did real estate sales for
14 years long have you been in Florida
that's the long story I'm here for six
months I was here last year for about
seven so and then I was on the west
coast for a short amount of time so I've
had a lot of moves which hasn't helped
I have zero retirement no health
insurance where where are you going to
settle down and make your life I have no
idea you need to decide that because you
need to get a job yeah well the work
that I was doing was remote so I can
work from anywhere
and I am currently attempting to replace
that I've been applying like a maniac
and getting interviews and I think
honestly it's because my rage is high
that I'm not able to get something more
quickly because my my debt is so high
how much debt do you have so I have
50,000 in credit cards the minimums on
that are 1,500 a month just for the
minimums I owe 24,000 to the IRS for
2017 I'm currently on a payment plan
with them of about 300 a month which
I'll pay off 110
apparently I haven't filed for 2018 yet
I was actually going to do an extension
just because I'm scared okay let's give
you some tips let's look at small steps
okay what what is happening is is you
have stuff flying at you and you're
giving me the these bits of information
that tells me it's flying at you from 14
different directions and you're
completely overwhelmed and and that's
where all the emotions coming from is
you just makes you scared because you
don't know you know where to start
okay so number one you don't pay the
credit cards a dime until you get a job
okay number two you get the
cryptocurrency out today today and you
put it in a savings account that gives
you twelve thousand dollars to work with
okay so we're not we're not worried
about food what is your rent
fifteen hundred okay why no because you
live in a really nice place in Panama
City Beach yeah well I live in an
apartment and long-term housing here is
really hard to find because that's all
short-term housing and that's all so
where are you going to settle
there's gypsy gypsy stuff start working
for you no it's not working for me if
I'm trying to employ you either
right so I need to see some stability if
I want to employ you if I'm looking on
the other side of your equation here
okay pay nothing on the credit cards you
are down to food shelter lights and
water and transportation do you have
debt on your car also no my car I own it
outright it's nine years old good okay
so gas in the car food lights and water
rent you don't pay money for anything
else right now oh you keep the keep the
three under dollars going on the IRS I
don't want them after you you file your
tax return on time even if you're unable
to pay there is a failure to file
penalty in addition to a failure to pay
penalty and there's no reason for you to
have extra tax bills right now and
that's even if I file an extension
correct no yeah you'll get filing
extension does not get you out of the
failure to pay you might as well file
long extension doesn't do any good all
it does is put off the fact that you
didn't file the return it does not help
you with the financial the money is
still due whether you file the extension
or not so you might as well just file we
don't get an extension on the taxes you
only get an extension on the paperwork
correct okay so go ahead and file and
there's no failure to file penalty that
way and you know then we're gonna start
to work on those taxes as well then
you've just got to get settled and
decide what you're gonna do and here's
an idea before you run out of money take
something for fifty thousand and let's
get the you know let's get food on the
table right and that was one of my
questions is because I've been trying to
replace what I was making
and it's obviously harder to get a
hundred thousand dollar job is also
though with the way you're doing things
because you're running around in circles
you feel like I'm control yeah you have
got to settle in and go I'm gonna live
here I'm gonna live there and based on
that these are my expenses based on that
I can go you can go wait tables and make
your basic bills the trim you don't have
to I don't want you to but you can
probably pick up a few you know just
freelance projects on project management
that's not even a full-time contract and
get enough money coming in to cover
basic stuff until you get your income
back up to the hundred range the good
news is you know how to make a hundred
thousand and you'll go back to making it
eventually but I don't want you to run
out of this eight this twelve thousand
dollars we got before that happens so do
not pay anyone except the IRS food
shelter clothing transportation
utilities get the tax return file get
the crypto out today get yourself
stabilized then you're gonna be able to
develop a plan for working through the
rest of this and we certainly can show
you how to do all of that then we can
get to stuff like getting out of debt
getting the IRS paid off you can pay off
twenty four thousand dollars for the IRS
in one year if you're back to making a
hundred again it's not a big deal you
can do that you'll be able to clear up
to $50,000 worth of death to 75 hours at
wente 5000 of the IRS you can clear up
every bit of that in two years once you
get back to making money and you get
stabilized again but right now it's just
you just doing backflips all the time